hertz moi je leur ai dit désolé de 30
ares quoi pourquoi tu rigoles vise les
je vois pas ce qu'il ya des excuses moi
je n'étais pas du tout recommence
déconne ou quoi c'est ma faute je
n'étais pas prête vie à l'école pas
enfin ça me déconcentre désolé
mademoiselle reding et oui les tenants
et bien si ça ne vous ennuie pas je
souhaiterais vous interrogez ça dépend
de quoi tout est peint si vous êtes très
méchant ou très gentil avec moi mais
gentil devine est très gentil ce pari
c'est raté en fait je suis très méchant
alors mesdemoiselles
vous allez coopérer
ben moi mais ça ne vous dérange pas
qu'on les observe
je n'ai rien à vous dire